hello everyone and welcome to a most
excellent game from round five of the
Kashima of Memorial it's quite an
eventful round in this game even though
a bit short it really is a positional
masterpiece I'm sure you're going to
enjoy it so without further ado let's
just check out the game it's
Vishwanathan Anand vs onigiri and honey
and the island opens with E 4 so we have
e 5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop
to b5 the root locus is on the board and
the Giri goes for knife to f6 the Berlin
defense and this is pretty much what
everyone plays today against against the
the rule opus with b3 and C butter to c5
the most often played line c3 with
castles by Geary Knight B to d2 and here
rook to e8 we have castles this is all
standard stuff we have a six Bishop
captures D captures of course and not
Knight to c4 it's interesting Quran and
nakamura played three games where
Khurana played the Knights to see for
one game Caruana won one game nakamura
one and one game between the two of them
was drawn so you know i colorful line
this Knight to c4 but okay Knight to c6
now increasing the defense of the e5
pawn we have rook to e1 by Anand and
interesting in one of the games Khurana
played be four against Nakamura he was I
believe that's the game Nakamura won so
here and it has a different plan here
honor please rook to e1 and now Bishop
the back to f8 and this is nothing new
this has all been played before D 400
seizes the center he captures C captures
and now there are no moves in this
position or c5 immediately going after
White's very strong center or Knight to
f6 just remembering back pressuring d4
pawn but the movie gear replaced is a
new move and it is over this moment the
move 12 that we have a completely new
game okay Anand capture some b6 with
Knight captures pawn captures here now
black has doubled be pawns and as you
can see white has a very strong center a
lot of central squares that aren't
controls but it's a trade off
as you can see Geary has the bishop pair
so if if gira can open the position up
make use of his bishops then black
should have the advantage here but we'll
see how how he fares with h3 by white b5
and now Bishop clear for Anand Anand
continues developing with Bishop to e6
now black develops the light square
bishop and now rook to e3 a very nice
rook lift and now f6 one of the
positions where it's actually okay to
play f6 just strengthening the e5 square
and now while white will have problems
if he wants to add a further advance the
center d5 in both a five are well
protected from blacks perspective b3 by
white and now comes Queen to d7 we have
Queen to c2 by white and rook a to d8
and here rook to d1 so now both sides
have pretty much completed development
both rooks are now active and well
honored the bishop and and the night are
doing very nicely
Gary's bishops are also also not bad
it's okay we have Queen to f7 by Giri
and Bishop back to g3 and here Queen to
h5 it's interesting
you still can't push something like c5
it would be very nice if you could to
trade off or force black to capture here
but the white will simply advance d5 and
you will simply a the white in in
advance in his very strong center you
will create a passed pawn for white
which is not something you want to do so
here after Queen to h5 what a Giri
played we have Queen to c7 under decides
to remain over the bishop all the way to
b6 we have looked at e7 attacking the
bishop the bishop goes to b6 and now
Bishop to b4 by giri just uh are the
bishop I mean it was very nice
controlling all of these squares but now
the bishop also controls these squares
so it's a it's a very nice dark square
bishop now with Knights the e1 are
deciding to go to d3 to push back the
dark square Bishop with Bishop to f7 and
now comes Knight to d3s plant and Bishop
goes back with Bishop to d6
rook dt 1 now on and doubles up on the
e-file and Bishop goes back to be 8 so
now the bishop did quite a trick first
goes to B 4 then to d6 dance to b8 and
now he controls this diagonal
but again a very nice dark square bishop
and here Anand increases his presence in
the center he goes f4 as a black has no
good ways of punishing this I know as
you can see just with the pawns Anand
has a immense central control here which
is you know there's an old saying in
chess he who can he who controls the
center shall win the game but we'll see
about that with f5 by giri and now as
black is no longer controlling e5 Gary
immediately ceases that outpost Knights
the e5 would you have to capture you
cannot allow that monster night to stay
there so Bishop captures on e5 d
captures on e5 and now F captures on
before Queen captures on e4 now Anand
has this beautiful rook rook Queen
battery along the e-file and also the F
pawn and the e pawn are ready to be
pushed and the upon is a very dangerous
pass pawn
so first rook to d2 just an excellent
score for the rook pressuring da to pawn
also will increase pressure towards the
g2 pond and Anand of course will not
allow this we have rook to eat too and
now first Bishop to d5 attacking the
Queen this was the threat you had to
block the rook here if you haven't
blocked it now there would be this
attack towards the g2 point which would
be pretty much the which would be
winning for black so Queen to e3
attacking the rook and now we have rook
captures rook captures Sonny - and now
Queen to a5 just blockading the DF point
from being pushed forward and also now
the bishop the Queen and the rook are
preventing the past a point from being
pushed forward so Anand has to decide
how to deal with this position black
seems to keep everything in check it's a
it's a nice game
the material is equal there are bishops
of opposite colors so you won't they
will not be able to oppose each other
and as you roll in bishops office
opposite color in games or just games
the side who's on the attack has the
advantage because the sides of defending
is basically a piece down now because
the bishops are unable to oppose each
other so here I feel free to pause the
video and try to figure out a way how to
how to handle this position from Anna's
perspective I'll give you a couple of
seconds it's just a-- you don't find
find the the the plant to play this game
you know I just realized that this is
the same water that was here from
yesterday and I didn't check if you know
maybe there were any bugs in it or
anything so I was very lucky this time
but you know you can never be too
careful you know summer is coming and
you know there are all sorts of crazy
bugs everywhere but okay for those of
you who found at the correct plan the
way are not played the congratulations
you are an excellent player and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show at g4 is the moon just you know
grabbing even more space forcing the
Queen to move you are preparing f-5e
success coming and you are just you know
going going after the black king we have
Queen to be one check by Gary King to f2
and now you have to be a little bit
careful but not not too much here you if
you go something like Queen to h1
doesn't really doesn't really do
anything for black but as it will be
played in the game we will show what
happens then first year we played h5 he
wants the bust open this beautiful punch
in that aren't created we have f5 by
Anand just pushing forward and then now
comes Queen to h1 and now you still have
to be careful for example if you try
something like e six then black can
capture capture go Queens you to check
after you move grab the g4 pawn and now
black prevented the white from further
pushing the pawns and also black is now
up material so here it would be it would
be a pleasant position for black not too
pleasant but you know they're fairly
present Pleasant so here after a queen
to h1 are not first has to make up a
safety move which I no doubt know that
you all know which it is it is pink to
g3 just you know a very nice safe square
for the King now the rook is also
controlling the g2 square there are no
tricks there are no tricks and the giri
has to decide what to do here we have
looked east 7 by giri and here on and
immediately pushes it back with Bishop
to c5 rook to e8 and now II 6 and here
well you can just imagine if you're
playing black here how do you how do you
deal with this position it's not not all
that easy
get rid played King to h7 and here
aren't just played Queen
five and it was in fact in this position
unmoved 39 that onigiri resigned the
game and the wonderful victory for
Vishwanath on Island
what if he resign well there's too many
threats from White's perspective if you
just let say capture the pond and rope
the Queen d6 check picks up the rook
black is getting checkmated very soon
and even if you don't if you try
something like rook to f8 maybe get rid
of this Bishop controlling g1 it doesn't
really matter why can't play anything
what can even just capture the rook and
after let's say Queen to f3 check or
something you can go King to h4 and
black has no moves no more checks are
possible and whatever you do is to
capture the rook then comes Queen
captures and g7 and this will be
checkmate so a really really impressive
game by Anand after Queen g5 onigiri
resigned and it's it's so one of those
games where you're not too sure where
where black made the mistake there was
no mistake in this game I don't just
play the strongest moves and the Giri
played almost the strongest moves and
you know I have to replay the 20 moves
in that fashion
one side will will gain the decisive
advantage which was the case here but it
is just you know 39 moves against the
Berlin it's just a positional
masterclass by Anand so you know a well
deserved the victory to say the least
I will be showing at least one more game
from this round of the gushie memorial
so we'll be showing the standings after
round 5 in that video which I'm probably
gonna upload maybe in an hour or two
we'll see how it goes
Ovid yeah that's the game I'm sure you I
hope you enjoyed that the Giri
definitely didn't I would like to thank
Matt play against Michael Cabral any
shank Botti Pro Lu William Miller and
Jana Schlesinger for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos
sure thing go for watching and I will
see you soon I like I said with another
game from the gajima of Memorial the 6th
edition so thank you and I will see you
soon